first of all I want to thank God I want
to say bismillah next about the flood
anything can happen under this wall that
is in the heavens and the earth
magnifies God he is the all-mighty the
all-wise
to him belongs the kingdom of the
heavens in the earth he gives life and
he makes to die and he is powerful over
everything he is the first and the last
outward and the inward he has knowledge
of everything now some of you might be
wondering what did the heavyweight
champion of the world Yahshua just say
well he said something that's the pure
natural way it's part of your nature
it's something that we have though we as
those who are submitted to the will of
God Muslims we say this every day before
we eat before we do an important act
when we come into our houses we say in
the name of God Almighty in the name of
Allah it's the same thing that Jesus
said it's the same thing that Moses said
is the same thing that all of the
messengers that God Almighty sent out of
his mercy for mankind to God mankind
they would all say bismillah they would
worship the One God alone without
associates or partners and it's very
nice to see Joshua have that come off of
his lips and in sha Allah God woman that
can be in his heart and you see him
saying it before he boards the plane so
you can go ahead and take because he has
a lot of fans people who watch him
people who admire him
why don't you start to reflect and think
deeper than boxing deeper than MMA
deeper than all of the entertainment
that's out there think about what's my
purpose in life why have I been created
why am I here and then ask the Creator
the one God alone to guide you it's a
great place to start because remembering
the show will be over and it will all
end and we're gonna have a departure
date just like you had a birth date
you're gonna have a departure date
you're gonna leave all these material
possessions behind and imagine someone
who's building a house and you spent all
your money and time and you're excited
now you're about to have your dream home
but you didn't plan for what comes after
that many people have they've built
their train dream homes and then shortly
sometime after that their departure date
hit him but they weren't prepared for
what came after here this life and we're
all going to depart from this world now
imagine if Joshua he didn't prepare for
his boat what would have happened he
would have got another loss on his
record but he prepared but what about us
the human beings shouldn't we prepare
for what comes after here when we depart
from this life and does it not make
sense that the one who created us he
created us for a purpose because we just
don't do things without a purpose
Anthony Joshua got in the ring there was
a goal he got in there for a purpose
imagine if they were boxing with no goal
no purpose it doesn't make sense the
same way it doesn't make sense that we
the human beings were created without a
purpose so some homework for you for
anyone out there is to ask the creator
for guidance a very simple homework say
guide me
why am I here why did you create me
guide me the one who created me guide me
guide me guide me so bismillah means in
the name of Allah in the name of the
Creator and that's the one the one God
the one creator who we want to ask
guidance from and the one we want to
tell us what we've been created for and
what is our purpose so start off with
that homework break the first Idol and
usually that first Idol is yourself
break through the following of one's
desires of the ego and humble yourself
stay humble asking for guidance from the
one who created you and then from there
be courageous enough when the truth
comes because you can be heavyweight
champion of the world you could be a UFC
star you could be the greatest athlete
and you got courage to get in there in a
fight but many of times people aren't
courageous enough when the truth comes
to accept the truth to live on the truth
and to share the truth thank you
assalamo alaikum peace be with you